[Music]
today it's time to give one of the most
divisive comedians
do adam sandler
a lot of critics have dismissed sandler
as the low point of modern comedy
his films have been called juvenile
amateurish lazy and just
plain awful after years of vicious
criticism
sandler says he no longer even reads his
own reviews
saying so i did stop reading them it
didn't make sense
to me and it screwed my thinking up a
little bit when we were writing the next
one me and my buddy were like
you think they're going to hate this if
we do this and we started saying
what's the difference the only time
sandler gets even a
modicum of critical respect is when he
steps out of his comfort zone and takes
on meteor roles
but even then critics use these films as
further proof of sandler's laziness
the implication seems to be if he's
capable of such
nuanced performances why has he
squandered his talents in tasteless
comedies
the same pattern repeated itself just
last year
sandler started one of his most
critically acclaimed films yet
uncut gems many even thought sandler
deserved an academy award nomination for
his performance
but critics still painted uncut gems as
a rare exception in sandler's career
a brief bright spot amidst his usual
dumpster fighters
however we here at wisecrack think the
opposite uncut gems
isn't a rare exception in sandler's
filmography rather it's the culmination
of sandler's entire career
that is to say sandler's past works
billy madison grown-ups mr deeds and yes
even jack and jill were merely covert
preparation for his best role yet
so welcome to this wisecrack edition on
the genius of adam sandler
spoilers ahead for uncut gems and a few
classic sandler comedies
but before we get into it i want to give
a shout out to rage shadow legends for
sponsoring this episode
raid is a massive hero rpg and is
available to download on mobile
and pc collect equip train and upgrade
your team of heroes to defeat bosses and
earn special prizes the more you play
the more you are rewarded with resources
that could help maximize your team's
strength
you can upgrade heroes by sacrificing
certain smaller heroes or
by making your way through the different
campaigns the game is constantly
updating so there is always something
fun and new to do
right now you can participate in the tag
team arena competition
which is the next level of pvp battles
in this series you can raid in a bracket
to win special rewards
it's a little more challenging than
regular gameplay but that only makes it
more fun
raid is free to play so download it now
using the links in the description
if you use our links that are a new
player you will receive 50 000 silver 50
gems one energy refill one clam boss key
five mystery shards one day xp booster
and one free champion
the executioner all this treasure will
be waiting for you here
the rewards will only be available for
the next 30 days so check it out now
now let's get back to the show on the
surface uncut gems seems like a pretty
big departure for the sandman
in the film sandler stars as howard
ratner a diamond district jeweler always
looking to make a quick buck
this time from a glitzy ethiopian opal
problem is
howard's a gambling addict do you take
lightning bets yeah but you don't want
any part of lightning
come on a thousand dollars a point okay
take this already in the hole for a
hundred grand to his lone shark
brother-in-law arno
after approximately 90 minutes of blood
pressure raising shenanigans
howard sells the opal to nba player
kevin garnett as a good luck charm
but instead of using this cash to pay
off his debts immediately
howard bets big on the celtics believing
garnett will have a great game
there's a bet in that bag i want you to
take all of it
all of it inside the bag and place it on
that how much is in the bag
there's a lot and locks arno and his
goons behind bulletproof glass in his
store to watch how the game plays out
the bet appears to pay off the celtics
win and howard scores the millions he's
been after
but it's too late when he unlocks the
door arno's goons are so fed up by his
antics they shoot him dead and rob his
jewelry store
not the typical sandler happy ending oh
my
god incredible if you haven't seen this
film
it is very good like a two hour long
panic attack that you somehow remember
fondly it's also a dark gritty drama
with not a single scatological joke or
pratfall to be found in its two-hour
plus run time
yet there's one thing uncut gems shares
with all of sandler's previous films see
throughout sandler's career he's
cultivated one specific comedic persona
no matter the role be it a wealthy heir
a waterboy the son of satan or a diamond
district
jeweler each sandler character is
essentially the same an emotionally
stunted man-child
in 1970 scholar philosopher and yugi and
psychoanalyst marie luis on friends
identified a growing trend in young men
they refused to grow the f up this
persona is called the pure eternus
latin for the eternal child in her book
the problem of the pure eternas
von france stated the man who identified
with the archetype of the pure eternist
remains too long in adolescent
psychology
that is all those characteristics that
are normal in youth of 17 or 18 are
continued into later life
it's worth noting that the problem of
the pure attorneys came out right on the
heels of the 1960s
a decade defined by the sudden emergence
of youth culture
the youth of the 1960s rebelled against
previous generations
rejecting traditional norms like the
nine to five communal duties and not
dropping acid
being young and carefree became
idealized in pop culture and people
began holding onto their youth for
far longer than was traditionally
acceptable q the man child
according to von friends most man
children share the same basic
characteristics they struggle to
maintain long lasting jobs and are
unable to find a place in society
because they refuse to adapt to social
norms
instead they sit around and do pretty
much nothing to quote von friends
the pure eternist lives in a continual
sleepy daze
the sleepy undisciplined long-legged
youth who merely hangs around his mind
wandering indiscriminately
so that sometimes one feels inclined to
pour a bucket of cold water over his
head
these men are often quite arrogant a
quality that stems from an inferiority
complex and false feelings of
superiority these men are also attracted
to women who can replace their mother
who can enfold them in her arms and
satisfy their every need
and they're prone to dangerous acts and
sports because they yearn to get away
from reality from the earth from
ordinary life
whether you accept von franz's take on
modern manhood or not
you can probably see how adam sandler's
early characters uniformly fit this
description
it's important to note that sandler
isn't just a work for hire comedian he's
also a co-writer on almost all of the
work in his lower brow
uvra thus it isn't just sandler's acting
but also his writing and storytelling
choices that helped construct his
man-child persona take sandler's
breakthrough performance in billy
madison
billy spends all his time lounging in a
pool and drinking himself into a stupor
behavior which certainly suggests a
desire to escape reality he has no
job prospects to speak of and absolutely
no desire to fit into conventional
society
the most pressing thing on billy's mind
shampoo is
better i go on first and clean the hair
conditioner is better i leave the hair
silky and smooth for this roll sandler
adopts what would become one of his
trademarks a high-pitched and garbled
voice
as if a grown man were attempting to
mimic a child's voice
ooh that wasn't very nice this
literalizes billy's refusal to grow up
when people criticize billy he
immediately lashes out his face
scrunching up in despair and anger like
a confounded toddler about to erupt i
hate cursive and i hate all of you
like the prototypical man child billy
also has a major inferiority complex
it's not a coincidence that his primary
antagonist is eric gordon a stuck-up
businessman who lords his harvard
education over billy
second-team all-american harvard
the only people billy can relate to on
any level at all
are first graders once back in
elementary school he's in his element
there his silly jokes aren't met within
different stairs but actual laughter
what do you think of that mr blue duck
that's quacktastic
even billy's romantic interest fits von
franz's pure attorney's description
teacher veronica vaughn serves as a
maternal figure to billy helping this
man-child
study and grow throughout sandler's
early films he consistently plays this
same childlike figure lashing out in an
adult world that doesn't know what to
make of him
in the first 10 minutes of abby gilmore
happy beats up a coach who dares to mock
him
then he goes home to his girlfriend a
teacher yet again and asks her to stay
the night because he's had a rough day
just like billy happy wants a maternal
figure to make everything better
but this time the girlfriend has no
interest in baby and sandler's man child
she calls happy a loser and leaves i am
not
spending the rest of my life with a
loser afterwards happy goes to the
batting cage
where he proceeds to let baseballs hit
him directly in the face
an active on france would undoubtedly
label a dangerous sport
happy through this pain seeks to escape
the reality of his failures
and the only person impressed by these
immature antics you guessed it
a child and sandler's next film the
water boy
he goes even further playing bobby a
juvenile man child who still lives with
his mama did he tell you about a little
bedtime problem
mama i'm begging you don't that's his
sheet back there
much of the comedy in the water boy
stems from bobby's childlike responses
to the adult world
is there a girl you're seeing seeing
i i i see a lot of girls again sandler
emphasizes the character's childlike
naivete
adopting a babyish lisp and stutter and
slouching like an uncomfortable kid at
school
and like a child bobby legitimately
struggles to retain eye contact with
anybody
however sandler got older his depictions
of the man trial began to grow
take 1999's big daddy in which sandler
stars is sonny kofax
a 32 year old slacker with no job or
prospects to speak of
the film opens exactly like happy
gilmore with sonny's girlfriend breaking
up with him because of his immature
lifestyle
why are you being so nuts to me lately
because you refuse to move on to the
next phase of your life but unlike
previous films big daddy focuses less on
sandler's immature antics and more on
his maturation
sandler here issues many of his early
trademark signatures like the baby voice
or childish slouch
instead sandler adopts a disaffected
slacker attitude
as if sonny were in a perpetual haze
watching life passing by but after sony
takes in an abandoned child he's forced
to grow up and become a father figure
sandler's character no longer wets the
bed now he's the one who has to clean up
the mess
by the end of big daddy sunny turns his
life around becoming a successful lawyer
with a wife and child of his own
that's a pretty big departure from i
gotta
send them back to the south oh
but this was just the beginning of
sandler's maturation when the comedian
reached his 40s he became a family man
literally and on screen sandler's films
during this later period reflect his own
personal growth as a husband and father
while presenting a more nuanced outlook
on the man child
sandler's later films typically
spotlight a former man child who now in
middle age feels weighed down by
domestic responsibilities
this sandler character yearns to return
to the freedom of childhood that is
he wants to become a man child once
again the film that best encapsulates
this later sandler period outlook
none other than the off-forgotten click
yeah that's right i said it
click in click sandler stars is michael
newman an overworked architect exhausted
by daily life
when michael gets a remote that can
rewind and fast forward through time he
also gets the opportunity to sidestep
all adult responsibilities and indulge
in juvenile antics once more
in essence michael gets to literally
become a man child one who can fart in
his boss's face sends consequences
michael can also skip past anything
that's too emotionally challenging
but by constantly fast forwarding past
his responsibilities michael ultimately
misses
out on the most significant parts of his
life neglecting his children and wife
until they leave him
by the end a tearful michael has learned
his lesson
sandler's films throughout the odds
consistently play out in this exact same
fashion
focusing on family men who yearn to
return to their childhood
yet who ultimately learn to embrace
their familial responsibilities
life can be difficult sometimes it gets
bumpy what with family and kids and
things not going
exactly like you planned but that's what
makes it interesting
in life the first act always exciting
the second act that's where the depth
comes in
which brings us full circle to uncut
gems a film that shows the dark side of
what happens when the man child never
quite grows up
sandler brilliantly takes his trademark
comedic persona and applies it to a
so-called
serious film howard has all the same
basic characteristics of sandler's
previous man-child roles
inferiority complex oscar's wrong i
could go out and get six appraisers
right now
five of them would say at least three
thousand dollars a carrick
check a need for a maternalish figure to
tell him everything's gonna be okay
even though she's at least 20 years
younger than him oh you betcha
prone to dangerous acts in sports now
i'm just describing the whole movie
howard constantly puts his life on the
line for a series of increasingly risky
bets
i mean all you have to do is take one
look at howard's bachelor pad to see
what a man travel he is
it's a 15 year old's dream come true
complete with
nyx memorabilia and a portrait of a
naked lady this has rendered all the
more pathetic given that howard's in his
50s what's more
howard constantly neglects his familial
duties his head always focused on his
latest scheme
howard's wife literally has to chastise
him into tucking his son into bed
rather than watch a basketball game that
he's bet on how would girls take an idea
of son
in the early manchild film sandler could
almost always rely on his family's
support no matter his antics but in
uncut gems howard is rendered all the
more tragic because
nobody has his back in fact his entire
family turns against him
i think you are the most annoying person
i have ever met
i hate being with you i hate looking at
you and if i had my way i would never
see you again howard's daughter disdains
him and his son can barely look at him
after discovering he has a mistress
who's the girl living in your apartment
and to add insult to injury it's
howard's own brother-in-law that's hired
the goons threatening to kill him
in a meta twist it's almost as if
howard's family mirrors the harshest
critiques leveled against sandler his
wife is a stand-in for all the critics
who instinctively find the comedian
annoying on screen
whereas his children are a stand-in for
everyone who thinks sandler's a
disappointment for wasting his talents
and slumming it in juvenile comedies
unlike big daddy and click where
sandler's characters see the error of
their ways and eventually grow up
howard never does two-thirds of the way
through uncut gems he finally has a
moment of clarity
lamenting to his girlfriend i can't
figure out what i'm supposed to do
everything i do is not going right
everything i do it's not going right i
don't know what to do
but howard unlike michael or sonny never
takes a moment to learn from his
mistakes
instead he doubles down on them coming
up with yet another get-rich-quick
scheme
and the results well speak for
themselves
sandler's career may have started out by
glorifying the man child but as he's
grown his perception of the persona has
apparently become far darker
culminating in uncut gems with the
man-child literal death
it's unnerving to think that all the
juvenile antics baby soda voices and
poop jokes have led to
well tragedy what was once labeled a
dumb archetype has morphed into a
shakespearean character flaw
ultimately it's howard's refusal to grow
up to change to learn to engage
with any semblance of reality that
proves to be as undoing
a character like howard should be
inherently unlikable yet because sandler
has grown up playing this character
through his entire career
he's able to inject howard with the
pathos and affability only someone who
knows the type like the back of his hand
could
this is the role that sandler was born
to play and the culmination of his
manchild persona it's almost
too fitting that the safety brother
spent years trying to convince sandler
to take on the role
who else could have played it to such
perfection so will adam sandler fulfill
his destiny of starring in movies that
aren't terrible
well maybe not so fast in a recent
interview sandler joked that if he
didn't get an oscar nomination for uncut
gems
he would to quote himself can come back
and do a movie again that is so bad on
purpose
just to make you all pay that's how i
get them perhaps proof the man child
never quite dies after all
but what do you guys think does uncut
gems mark peak adam sandler man
childhood where does he even go from
here
let us know what you think in the
comments big thanks to our awesome
patrons for supporting us
hit that subscribe button and as always
thanks for watching later
[Applause]
[Music]
you